[Musique]
Bernard Stigler, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Euh, ça fait à peu
près 1 an et 3 mois qu'on s'était pas
vu.
Comment ça va ?
Pas trop mal compte tenu du contexte. Je
trouve que je m'en sors bien. Mais
est-ce qu'on peut parler guerre
économique, géopolitique, Europe, gilets
jaunes ? Vous choisissez le sujet pour
commencer ?
Bah oui, je pense que il faut entrer par
le sujet de la guerre économique.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on appelle ainsi ?
Enfin, moi en tout cas, qu'est-ce que
j'appelle ainsi ? avec un groupe de gens
qui s'est constitué le 22 septembre
2018 à Londres
à l'initiative de l'Institut de
recherche innovation et de de
Serpentines Gallery de Londres.
Nous avons et de Arsenustrialiste, nous
avons créé un groupe
qui travaille depuis
donc quelques mois maintenant
à l'écriture d'un texte qu'on a appelé
un memorandum of understanding
comme le fait la Commission européenne
quand elle s'adresse à la Grèce.
dans ce qui est un texte dans lequel
nous alors que nous comptons remettre le
10 janvier 2020 à Genève
au palais des nations,
c'est-à-dire dans le bâtiment qui a
hébergé la société des nations qui a été
créée le 10 janvier 1920, il y a donc
100 ans, il y aura 100 ans
et qui avait été créé comme vous le
savez dans le but deème guerre mondiale.
C'était juste après la première guerre
mondiale. C'était dans le sillage du
traité de Versailles qui avait été signé
à Paris en 1919.
Et comme vous le savez aussi, 19 ans
plus tard, une deuxième guerre mondiale
éclatait
euh à la suite de laquelle en 1945 fut
créé en remplacement de la Société des
nations, l'Organisation des Nations-
Unies.
Don le siège est aujourd'hui à New York.
Euh nous avons pris l'initiative avec un
certain nombre de personnes de d'horizon
varié, des scientifiques, des juristes,
des économistes,
des artistes, des citoyens,
des ingénieurs.
Environ 30 à 40 personnes, je me
souviens, j'ai pas fait le compte exact,
c'est en train de s'élargir et des gens
qui viennent d'un peu partout dans le
monde.
Nous avons pris l'initiative de
nous adresser à l'Organisation des
Nations- Unies
pour dire que le en 2020,
c'est-à-dire 70 ans, un peu plus 75 ans
après la création de l'ONU,
il y a une troisème guerre mondiale qui
est en cours.
L'ONU a peut-être pas trop mal fait son
travail pour éviter une 3è guerre
mondiale atomique pour le moment.
Alors, est-ce que c'est l'ONU ou est-ce
que c'est
ce qu'on appelle la guerre froide qui a
empêché
laissons le problème de côté ? C'est un
vrai sujet très important mais d'abord
je suis pas compétent et en plus c'est
pas de ça dont j'ai envie de parler.
Mais en revanche, ce que je voudrais
dire, c'est que en particulier depuis la
fin des années 70,
à partir du moment où
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle la
révolution conservatrice, c'est-à-dire
ce que certains appellent
l'ultralibéralisme,
euh qui est devenu depuis le
libertarianisme
de droite,
euh une guerre économique a commencé qui
avait qui a mis complè complètement
en l'air ce qui avait été l'objet de la
convention de Philadelphie
qui avait pour but de dans le cas de la
guerre froide aussi hein d'ailleurs de
protéger le travail de garantir un
certain nombre de
de protection
euh pour les travailleurs, pour les
entrepreneurs et cetera et de faire en
sorte que disons qu'il a une relative
justice sociale qui fasse aussi que le
système économique soit vertueuse,
c'est-à-dire que la production trouve
ses marchés et cetera et cetera. Tout ça
a commencé à être à être détruit à
partir de la fin des années 70 la suite
d'un débat d'ailleurs qui a eu lieu
surtout entre les conservateurs
britanniques et les républicains
américains. C'est comme ça que madame
Satcher est devenu premier ministre
de la Grande-Bretagne et que
Ronald Rean est devenu le président des
États-Unis
et ils ont mené une guerre idéologique
d'abord
surtout en direction de l'Europe à cette
époque- làà pour liquider en fait ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une sorte de paix
économique qui avait été signée
en tout cas à l'intérieur des sociétés
industrielles de l'Ouest.
et qui faisait que bah par exemple
bah celle était développé ce qu'on
appelait les 30 glorieuses que les les
gens avaient le sentiment quand j'étais
petit. Moi quand j'avais 10 ans, c'était
en 1962, même s'il y a eu l'affaire de
Cuba comme on dit, c'est-à-dire
la crainte d'une guerre mondiale
qui a duré quelques jours quand même
hein, de d'actualité de suspense.
Parmi cela, dans l'ensemble, les gens
pensaient que l'avenir était ouvert,
voilà, que leurs enfants vivraient mieux
queeux, qu'ils iraient tous plus ou
moins à l'école ou à l'université, que
bref, on se fais on se posait pas de
questions par ailleurs sur ce qu'on
appelle l'anthropocène, ça n'existait
pas, ça existait bien entendu mais le
mot n'existait pas, la notion n'existait
pas même si en 1971
le MIT a publié un rapport, le fameux
rapport MEDOS, mais que en même temps
deux autres Autres textes très
importants sont apparus.
Un de Nicolas Georges Kugan,
un économiste qui fut un assistant de
Joseph Schumpetter,
l'inventeur du concept de destruction
créatrice et qui lui avait dit très
bien, très bien, très très brillant mais
vous appuyez sur la physique
newtonienne. Or la physique n'est pas
newtonienne aujourd'hui et donc vous
tenez pas compte de l'entropie. Au même
moment, Arnold Toinby, un grand
historien anglais, avait publié un texte
extraordinaire où il disait "Voilà, il
faut lire Vladimir Wernsky, la
biosphère.
La biosphère est aujourd'hui beaucoup
mousculée par l'activité humaine
industrielle et ça pourrait se terminer
en catastrophe."
Euh alors
ces trois auteurs
euh Mose, le couple MOS
euh Arnold Toinby, Nicolas Georges Kogen
annonce en fait en 1971, les trois sont
pliés en 71 ce que maintenant nous
connaissons tous
et dont une jeune suédoise dont on nous
parle beaucoup comme vous avez dû
entendre parler d'elle toute jeune
suédoise
euh dit maintenant ça suffit. Voilà,
nous nous sommes une génération dont on
nous promet que en fait notre avenir est
totalement compromis. Le GC
a remis de nouvelles estimations
il y a un an beaucoup plus préoccupante
que le rapport 2014 qui était déjà très
préoccupant.
Le secrétaire général de l'ONU a fait un
discours en disant "Il ne nous reste que
10 ans."
Euh et en attendant, que se passe-t-il ?
Ben, il se passe rien. Il se passe rien.
Sauf que, en effet, euh il y a des par
exemple des lycéens dans le monde entier
maintenant qui ne vont plus à l'école,
au lycée le vendredi.
Euh, je dis dans le monde entier, c'est
parti de Suède et de Belgique.
Ça s'est étendu à l'Allemagne, à la
France, mais aussi à l'Australie.
quelques-uns aussi aux États-Unis.
Il faut soutenir ce mouvement de la
jeunesse qui est un mouvement
qui n'est pas dans une posture comme on
dit une révolte d'adolescents et cetera.
Non, qui pose une question absolument
fondamentale, c'est nous écoutons ce que
dit l'ONU, nous le prenons au sérieux et
donc nous vous demandons et s'adresse
aux États de prendre ça au sérieux.
Alors bah nous nous essayons aussi de
prendre ça au sérieux.
Alors quand je dis nous, c'est des gens
qui viennent de des mathématiques, de la
physique, de la biologie, de la
climatologie,
euh de l'économie, du droit, de la
philosophie,
de le des de des technologies de la
formation, de la communication, de ce
qu'on appelle les computer sciences et
cetera et cetera. pas mal d'artistes
aussi et de gens comme ça donc qui
viennent d'Europe,
de toute l'Europe, de l'Est comme
l'Europe de l'Ouest, euh d'Asie,
de l'Inde, du Japon.
Nous avons des contacts en Chine. En
Chine, c'est plus compliqué pour les
gens d'intervenir au nom de la Chine.
Donc il ne participe pas directement au
groupe, mais nous échangeons beaucoup
avec des Chinois aussi. Nous avons
commencé à engager discussion avec des
africains avec des grands personnalités
africaines avec l'Amérique latine
et nous sommes en train de rédiger donc
que ce memorandum of understanding.
Nous avons repris le la terminologie
officielle
des actes diplomatiques de ce genre qui
a été aussi utilisé pour donner sa
feuille de route comme on le dit sur les
médias à la Grèce.
Nous nous voulons faire un méand
understanding tout à fait différent
tout à fait différent et qui prend au
sérieux d'abord ce que disent les trois
auteurs dont je parlais tout à l'heure.
J'ouvre une parenthèse avant qu'on
déploie le l'argumentaire du mémorandum.
Est-ce que ça va pas être unème papier
qui va terminer dans une éème table ou
sur une éème poubelle ? Quels sont les
les moyens est-ce que vous avez designé
une stratégie plutôt offensive, plutôt
corrosive, plutôt attentiste, plutôt
Alors, avant de parler de la stratégie,
je vais parler du fond.
Quel est le fond ?
Le fond c'est la guerre économique.
Cette guerre économique, elle détruit le
monde en ce moment à très très grande
vitesse et elle a terriblement accélérée
depuis la disruption, c'estàdire depuis
la les réseaux numériques qui accélèrent
énormément les transformations et
malheureusement en renforçant toutes les
tendances négatives de l'anthropocène.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que le renforcement
des tendances négatives ? Qu'est-ce qui
est négatif ? Ce qui est négatif, c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'entropie.
Depuis 1865,
depuis que Claudius a produit le mot
entropie.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que l'entropie ?
C'est une une loi, c'est la Einstein
disait la loi la plus universelle de
l'univers.
C'est une loi qui fait que l'univers,
contrairement à ce qu'a cru l'humanité
de tout temps jusqu'à ce moment-là,
l'univers se transforme.
C'est un processus et ce processus est
gouverné par la dissipation irréversible
de l'énergie.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la
thermodynamique.
La thermodynamique a engendré un grand
débat au 19e siècle sur ce qu'on a
appelé la mort thermique de l'univers.
Puisque le si on applique cette loi,
l'univers se refroidit et donc il va
vers
indéfiniment vers son refroidissement
complet.
C'est ce qui a conduit au concept de ce
qu'on appelle la flèche du temps au 20e
siècle.
Et c'est ce qui par ailleurs a conduit
Erwin Schrodinger, un mécanicien
quantique, un physicien
à réfléchir, le fameux théoricien de du
chat de Schrodinger en effet, à
réfléchir euh
à
la aux conditions dans lesquelles du
point de vue d'un physicien, on peut
décrire ce que c'est que le vivant.
Et donc ça, ce sont des conférences
qu'il a donné en Irlande en 1944
dans lesquels il s'est demandé pour moi
physicien qu'est-ce que c'est que la vie
? Est-ce que je peux rendre compte de ce
que c'est que la vie du point de vue de
la physique ?
Et ça a été publié, c'est un petit livre
qu'on trouve traduit en français chez
plusieurs éditeurs de poche. Ça
s'appelle Qu'est-ce que la vie ? Et je
recommande tout le monde de le lire.
C'est un livre accessible, pas toujours
très facile mais très accessible, très
court. Donc ça se lit en en une ou de ou
deux soirées ou trois. Euh et qu'est-ce
que ça dit ? a dit le vivant
c'est ce qui s'accepte d'une loi de la
physique, c'est la loi de l'entropie de
manière temporaire et locale.
C'est-à-dire qu'un être vivant, c'est un
être qui
pour un temps donné, alors ça peut être
une journée pour une éphémère, insecte,
ça peut être de ou 300 ans pour un
éléphant. Pour un être humain
aujourd'hui, c'est
un éléphant en 100 ans.
Pardon ?
Un éléphant 100 ans.
100 ans. Voilà. Alors, c'est les tortues
de ou 300 ans, hein. En tout cas, c'est
variable et ça et ça change dans le
temps d'ailleurs puisque les êtres
humains visent plus longtemps
aujourd'hui qu'autre fois. Euh même si
la l'espérance de vie est en train de
baisser maintenant un peu partout dans
le monde et surtout dans les grands pays
industriels. Mais en tout cas, ce qui
fait qu'un être vivant vit, c'est qu'il
a une capacité à s'accepter de
l'enthropie temporairement et
localement. Alors, qu'est-ce que veut
dire temporairement ? Bah, c'est la
durée de sa vie. Et qu'est-ce que veut
dire localement ? C'est l'espace de son
enveloppe, c'est donc corporel plus
l'écosystème dans lequel il vit,
l'espèce et cetera, ce qu'on appelle le
biotop. Voilà. Euh au niveau de
l'espèce, sachant qu'il y a des espèces
qui disparaissent, d'autres qui
apparaissent et cetera. Alors, si je dis
tout cela, c'est pour une raison très
précise. C'est parce que lorsque Nicolas
Georges Korogan a publié un livre qui
s'appelle Antropilo and Economic
Process,
publié par Harvard où il a enseigné et
où enseignait Schumpeter,
et bien il dit "L'économie actuelle
repose sur la la physique de Newton. Or,
la physique n'est plus Newtonienne.
Newton, c'est une exception à la limite
de la physique. La physique, c'est
aujourd'hui, c'est la physique
thermodynamique. Voilà. À partir de là,
il faut repenser les bases scientifiques
de l'économie. Alors, pourquoi est-ce
que je dis tout cela ?
C'est théoriquement très intéressant,
mais c'est surtout pratiquement
fondamental.
Si maintenant vous vous tournez vers ce
que Paul Cruten
prix Nobel de chimie et climatologue a
dit à Mexico en 2000, c'est-à-dire nous
sommes dans l'anthropocène.
Si vous lisez l'abondante littérature
qu'il y a maintenant sur l'anthropocène,
il y a des centaines de livres
maintenant sur l'anthropocène qui
essayent de vous expliquer ce que c'est
que l'anthropocène, quand est-ce que ça
commence et cetera et cetera. Grosso
modo, il y a plus ou moins un consensus
pour dire ça commence au 18e siècle vers
la fin du 18e siècle avec l'exploitation
du charbon en Angleterre
et ça se développe d'abord dans toute
l'Europe occidentale puis l'Europe et
les États-Unis puis finalement le monde
entier aujourd'hui. Et qu'est-ce que
c'est ? c'est la destruction de la
planète
et ça accélère surtout après la deuxième
guerre mondiale
et cette accélération le JC nous dit en
2014 si on ne ralentit pas dans les 20
ans qui viennent on atteindra un niveau
de réchauffement de la planète à la fin
du 21e siècle de 3,8° qui sera
insupportable pour pour la planète en
tout cas pour les formes supérieures de
la vie et pour l'espèce humaine. Donc il
faut diminuer la production de CO2. Ça
c'était en 2014, en 2000
en 2018, ils ont revu à la hausse la
hausse de température, c'est beaucoup
plus grave. C'est 5,8°
et c'est une accélération qui fait que
le président que le secrétaire général
de l'ONU donc a pris l'initiative d'un
discours en disant maintenant il nous
reste 10 ans parce qu'ils ont ralenti,
ils ont raccourci la durée de voilà de
réaction. Il y a eu 13300
13000 13584 chercheurs qui ont publié un
texte surtout des biologistes, des
zoologues et cetera, euh disant à peu
près la même chose et qu'il fallait
changer les règles de l'économie. Mais
euh tout le monde dit ça mais en même
temps personne ne dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer exactement dans les
règles de l'économie ? Donc nous nous
sommes dit nous allons nous employer à
ça. Donc entre économiste,
mathématicien, juriste, biologistes et
cetera et cetera. La biologie est très
importante dans cette affaire.
Des psychiatres dans le groupe.
Il y a des psychiatres aussi. Ouais.
Et
ce que nous posons, c'est que il faut
commencer à transformer sérieusement les
règles de l'économie. Pourquoi ? Parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'anthropocène ? Alors anthropocène
c'est écrit avec un A et un H. Ça vient
d'entrhropos. Donc anthropocène, ça veut
dire géologique dominée par l'homme où
l'homme est devenu le premier facteur de
transformation des processus
géologiques.
Euh il y a eu un débat d'ailleurs au
début chez les géologues où ils étaient
plutôt rétifs, je dirais, à cette
proposition qui venait pas des géologues
mais des chimistes. Et puis finalement,
il y a eu un autre débat qui s'est tenu
il y a 2 ans et demi, je crois
maintenant, bientôt 3 ans en Afrique du
Sud à la société mondiale de géologie.
Et finalement, la société mondiale de
géologie a admis l'hypothèse en se
donnant un certain temps pour la
confirmer. Voilà, je sais plus
exactement combien de temps, mais si je
vous le dis, c'est parce que ça a
suscité d'avoir des résistances tout ça,
puis progressivement toutes ces
résistances tombent parce que les choses
sont évidentes en réalité.
Euh alors ce qui est pas évident par
contre, c'est de dire est-ce qu'une
échelle de 250 ans c'est une échelle
géologique ? Est-ce que les modèles de
la géologie sont signif sont utilisables
dans une à une telle échelle ? Bon, ça
ce sont des grandes questions, je vais
pas vous en parler. Nous en parlons dans
ce groupe évidemment. Euh maintenant, ce
que je voudrais dire, c'est que nous
travaillons nous aujourd'hui à essayer
de concevoir une nouvelle comptabilité
mondiale de l'économie. Parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'économie au
sens moderne ? une économie fondée sur
la comptabilité. Joseph Max Weber l'a
l'avait très bien vu déjà dans l'esprit
du capitalisme où il avait montré
l'importance des des normes comptable.
La comptabilité aujourd'hui, ben c'est
ce qui permet de faire de la
certification, de certifier par exemple
les comptes d'une entreprise, c'est ce
qui permet de gérer un budget national,
c'est ce qui permet de faire des des
négociations d'accords internationaux
dans tous les domaines. Et nous pensons
que ces règles comptables, elles sont
basées sur des indicateurs économiques
qui sont faux et qui ont pour en gros
pour effet très pervers de valoriser
l'augmentation de l'entropie. C'est dire
que plus vous produisez de l'entropie,
plus vous êtes solvable. Sauf que vous
êtes solvable à court terme, mais à long
terme, vous détruisez la planète.
L'anthropocène en fait, c'est une
augmentation générale de l'entropie.
L'entropie, ça a trois dimension
aujourd'hui. L'entropie, au départ,
c'est une notion de physique. C'est donc
les thermodynamiciens qui calculent ce
qu'on appelle le taux d'entropie, c'est
le le taux de dissipation de l'énergie.
Mais cette notion a été introduite en
biologie via Ravin Schrodinger, mais pas
seulement lui, hein. Alfred Lotka dont
je vous parler tout à l'heure, bien
avant Schrodinger avait traduit ces
questions là aussi en biologie.
Euh et donc par exemple ce qu'on appelle
la la 6e extinction de masse
qui est quand même une réalité puisque
en un siècle, on a perdu 70 % des des de
la diversité biologique, ce qui est
absolument colossal. Et quand on sait
que le vivant c'est une pyramide et que
ce qui est en haut de la pyramide
suppose de s'appuyer sur ce qui est en
dessous, et bien si on perd de la
biodiversité, on perd aussi de l'espoir
de durabilité de ce qui en rôle de la
pyramide, c'est-à-dire nous et les et
les vivants supérieurs.
Euh mais il y a la l'entropie, c'est
également dans le champ de
l'information.
Et l'entropie informationnelle
aujourd'hui, on envoie très très bien
les effets. C'est l'augmentation de la
stupidité d'ide masse à laquelle ni vous
ni moi nous n'échappons. Parce que comme
vous sans doute, moi en sortant, je vais
regarder probablement mon smartphone et
cetera et cetera. Nous sommes sous le
contrôle d'un système informationnel qui
aujourd'hui nous empêche de plus en plus
de penser par nous-même, de réfléchir,
de faire fonctionner notre notre noèise
comme disait les grecs, c'estd notre
pensée. La noésis, ça veut dire la
pensée. C'est l'époque de la
dénétisation par les technologies de
l'information, ce qui est extrêmement
grave et ça fait que Donald Trump par
exemple dirige les États-Unis, ce qui
est pas très rassurant. Alors,
tout ça c'est la concrétisation de
l'augmentation des taux d'entropie dans
tous les domaines de la réalité dans la
biosphère. Et c'est ce qui fait que oui,
par exemple, le GC disait septembre
dernier de l'année dernière, voilà, il
reste 12 ans, après c'est trop tard,
plus rien ne sera récupérable. Alors,
nous nous pensons qu'il faut se remuer
et que pour se remuer, il s'agit pas
d'écrire un rapport pour qu'il aille
dans un tiroir. Il s'agit de mobiliser
des communautés scientifiques,
économiques, citoyennes, artistiques,
juridique et cetera et cetera. Et pour
poser les vraies questions. Quelles sont
les vraies questions ?
Alors là, c'est ce qu'on essaie nous
d'apporter d'un petit peu nouveau
peut-être par rapport au débat général.
Je vous parlais de Nicolas Georges
Kurogan, un économiste reconnu qui est
au départ un mathématicien
qui fait de l'économétrie. Voilà pour
Joseph Schumpeter notamment.
Mais Georges Kurogan, il publie ce livre
en 1971 en s'appuyant sur un article qui
a été publié en 1945
par un biologiste qui s'appelle Alfred
Lotka, lui-même mathématicien qui est
connu parce qu'il a il a fait la fameuse
équation de l'OTCA Voltera qui décrit
des rapports pro prédateurs euh dans les
années 20 1920. C'est un mathématicien
qui fait des mathématiques appliquées à
la biologie et qui intègre euh des
modèles venus de l'entropie. pour faire
des statistiques sur les disons sur la
biologie des populations. Voilà, des
grandes des grands nombres de
populations. Mais en 1945,
après avoir d'ailleurs déjà écrit un
certain nombre de choses sur ce registre
là, mais sans les avoir consolidé et
synthétisé dans un article,
à la fin de la guerre mondiale,
il publie un texte extrêmement important
euh qui paraît dans une revue américaine
qui s'appelle Human Biology
que je vous recommande d'aller voir
1945. l'autre cas L O T K A biology.
Vous tapez ça sur Google, vous tombez
directement sur le papier. Et qu'est-ce
que dit l'autre cas ? Il dit "L'espèce
humaine est une espèce très
particulière.
C'est une espèce vivante.
Donc elle est soumise à l'entropie et à
la néganthropie. Disons, elle elle
produit de la néganthropie ou de
l'anti-enthropie de pardon de l'entropie
négative dans dans l'entropie. Mais par
ailleurs, la différence des êtres
vivants qui produisent de l'entropie
négative via leurs organes vivants,
leurs yeux, leur cœur, leurs intestin et
cetera, et bien l'espèce humaine produit
ça à travers des organes artificiels,
par exemple des usines de chimie,
euh par exemple des semences
sélectionnées et cultivées avec des
technologies
agricoles et cetera et cetera.
Et il ajoute
ces organes artificiels, ils accélèrent
énormément l'évolution.
C'est incomparable. L'homme évolue 1000
fois 10000 fois plus vite que les
espèces issues de l'évolution du vivant.
Et le problème c'est que par ailleurs
ces organes à la différence ça c'est moi
qui le dis, c'est pas l'autre cas, c'est
moi qui commente l'autre cas.
Maintenant, quand je ce que je vais dire
maintenant, c'est qu'à la différence des
organes naturels qui sont spontanément
voués à limiter l'entropie, euh tout est
fait dans un corps d'être vivant, que ce
soit un arbre, un mammifère ou un
insecte pour limiter l'entropie et tous
les organes coopèrent entre eux pour ça.
Et bien, les organes artificiels peuvent
augmenter l'entropie.
Alors ça ça fait longtemps que
personnellement je dis que les objets
techniques puisque les org artificieles
ce sont les objets techniques. Alors ce
que j'appelle un objet technique c'est
pas forcément un ordinateur hein. Ça
peut être une chaussure, un marteau,
une assiette, des lunettes et même un
mot parce qu'un mot c'est un produit
social. C'est un produit qui est pas
produit par la biologie.
C'est moi je dis depuis très longtemps
que ces réalités techniques sont des
pharmacas, ce qui est le pluriel de
pharmacon en grec. un pharmacone en
grec, c'est un poison et un remède. En
tout cas, dans le langage de Socrate,
Socrate dit l'écriture, c'est un poison
et un remède. Ça peut faire des choses
très très bien. Par exemple, fonder la
loi de la cité, par exemple, permettre
la géométrie, l'histoire de la Grèce.
Mais ça permet aussi aux sophistes de
manipuler les esprits. Ça provoque la
guerre civile et c'est très dangereux.
Donc il faut prescrire le pharmacon,
faut pas laisser par exemple n'importe
qui utiliser n'importe quoi. Alors nous
nous disons aujourd'hui
en 2019 et nous le dirons surtout le 10
janvier 2020, nous avons énormément
développé les organes artificiels et en
fait on a énormément augmenté
l'entropie.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des gens qui gagnent
énormément d'argent avec ces
technologies qui permettent de
d'augmenter de l'entropie parce que ça
rapporte de produire de l'entropie. Mais
ça ça détruit la planète. Donc à très
court terme, ça détruit tout le monde en
plus. Alors Elon Musk veut s'en aller
sur Mars avec sa fusée et cetera. Bon
peut-être qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui
iront sur Mars, mais d'abord s'ils vont
sur Mars et que la Terre ne les soutient
pas, ils vont pas tenir très longtemps
sur Mars.
Et et Laurent Alexandre qui nous dit que
la technologie et la science vont nous
sortir.
Bien sûr, je vais pas parler de lui
parce que c'est devenu un bouffon
celui-là. Donc, j'ai pas le temps à
perdre à parler avec des bouffons. Mais
ce que je soutiens moi, c'est que
à très court terme, pour tout le monde,
y compris pour le bouffon Laurent
Alexandre, tout ça est n'est pas viable.
Tout ça c'est le produit d'une guerre
économique. Cette guerre économique qui
a commencé en fait dès le début euh de
la l'ère industrielle mais qui a produit
d'ailleurs de temps en temps des guerres
des guerres militaires soit locales soit
mondiales. Deux guerres mondiales. Cette
guerre économique est elle-même devenue
mondiale aujourd'hui et elle menace
d'ailleurs de provoquer une guerre
militaire parce que les tensions entre
l'Asie et les États-Unis au sein de
l'Asie même et cetera sont deviennent
quand même extrêmement fortes et avec
des personnages qui nous paraissent pas
extrêmement fiables dans leur capacité à
disons
raisonner à froidement. Voilà, on a
l'impression que c'est plus tout à fait
l'ordre du jour. Donc il y a de quoi
être extrêmement inquiet de savoir que
on est au bord en fait d'un effondrement
par exemple de l'accès à l'eau, de
l'accès à l'air, de l'accès au métorar,
de l'accès à peu près à tout avec une
croissance démographique absolument
terrible, immense, des tas de gens qui
souffrent de la fin et ça n'est qu'un
début.
une augmentation du niveau de l'eau qui
fait que par exemple au Kerala l'année
dernière,
l'été dernier, il y a eu des millions de
maisons détruites, des millions de gens
à la rue et le Kerala essaie de s'en
remettre mais c'est un effet direct du
réchauffement climatique.
Tout cela fait que il faut absolument
réagir et que pour réagir et ben faut
poser les bons problèmes. Les bons
problèmes c'est des problèmes d'abord de
savoir ce que c'est que l'anthropocène
et comment le combattre. L'anthropocène,
c'est avant tout un problème
d'enthropie. Donc le problème, c'est de
baser l'économie sur la lutte contre
l'entropie. Et ce que nous sommes en
train de faire, alors d'abord ces
sujets-là, nous les traitons en scène
Saint-Den parce que ça fait 2 ans que
j'ai lancé un programme
avec pleine commune, avec aussi quelques
acteurs économiques qui nous
accompagnent
qui sont pas des petits acteurs euh des
acteurs institutionnels comme la Caisse
dépôt et consignation, mais aussi
d'assau système orange,
euh d'Anon et un certain nombre d'autres
entreprises
comme des banques, la société générale
et cetera et cetera qui s'intéresse
beaucoup à ce que nous disons. Pourquoi
ils s'y intéressent ? Bah parce que
parce qu'ils sont convaincus que nous
avons raison et que et qu'il y a un très
très gros problème qui se pose et que ce
problème, il faut commencer à essayer de
le traiter pratiquement et concrètement.
Donc ce qu'on est en train de faire,
c'est pas un rapport, ce sont des
actions d'expérimentation. Pour le
moment, on a commencé dans Sain
Saint-Denis, mais on discute. Je vais en
Équateur au mois de juillet, ça fait
déjà plusieurs années que je discute
avec l'Équateur. Je discute avec l'Inde,
je parlais du Carala tout à l'heure, je
discute avec la Chine, euh avec
l'Angleterre, avec la Belgique.
Les États-Unis, c'est un peu compliqué
pour moi parce que j'ai plus le droit
d'y mettre les pieds. Donc voilà. Mais
donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de beau ?
Bah, j'ai fait des bêtises quand j'étais
jeune, mais euh depuis depuis que Donald
Trump est devenu président des
États-Unis, on m'a retiré mon visa. Donc
voilà. Donc je peux plus aller aux
États-Unis. Mais nous avons beaucoup
d'amis aux États-Unis, bien entendu qui
qui nous discutons de tout ça et dont
certains sont membres de ce groupe.
Alors en tout cas,
ce que je veux dire, c'est que ce que
nous sommes en train de faire en ce
moment, c'est d'écrire un projet de
traité de paix économique.
Un projet de traité de paix économique
qui est fondé sur quoi ? l'ambition de
se donner 10 ans puisque c'est le temps
que nous donne l'ONU en fait pour lancer
une méthode de travail pour faire muter
l'économie.
OK. Alors à mon tour.
Donc là on va voir les États-Unis avec
ce ce traité ses actions locales et on
lui dit en gros on va ralentir.
Les marchés financiers vont réagir
comment à ce ralentissement à cette
décroissance ?
Il est pas question de ralentir ni de
décroître. Bien au contraire. Il faut
accélérer et accroître. Simplement ce
qu'il faut accélérer, c'est
l'enrichissement des pauvres. Il faut
accroître leur pouvoir d'achat et cetera
et surtout leur leur façon de vivre
intelligemment plutôt que de consommer
des bagnoles dont on a plus besoin et de
de gaspiller du caoutchou, de l'essence,
du métal et cetera et ça travaillons
autre chose. Donc il s'agit absolument
pas de décroître. Moi, je suis contre la
décroissance. Je dis toujours, il y a
350000 bébés qui naissent tous les
jours, il faut s'en occuper, il faut les
nourrir. C'est pas du tout de la
décroissance. Non, c'est de la justice
sociale, mais c'est surtout de la
rationnalité économique. Donc le
problème c'est de lutter contre
l'entropie. Euh,
il y a un plan médiatique aussi échanger
les arcanes du plan médiatique.
Est-ce qu'on a pas de plan médiatique ?
Est-ce qu'on va prendre le le
Moi, je crois pas du tout au médias. Je
je
Est-ce qu'on va prendre le contrôle de
des agences de commun ?
Je pense qu'il faut pas prendre le
contrôle non plus. On n pas besoin de
ça. Elle s'écroule toute seule. Donc euh
c'est vous savez, moi je suis pas là
pour aller détruire des trucs, je suis
là pour en construire des trucs. Par
contre, je suis en train de discuter, je
peux pas vous dire avec qui parce que
c'est confidentiel, mais avec des des
autorités publiques et de grandes
autorités scientifiques pour essayer
d'inventer enfin quelque chose qui soit
à la hauteur de la numérisation
euh qui se produit et dans le champ des
médias qui soient qui redeviennent ce
qui étaient les médias au 18e et au 19e
siècle, c'est-à-dire un espace de débat
public qui élève l'intelligence
collective et cetera et cetera. Et ça il
le cas maintenant
pardon
c'est plus le cas maintenant. Bah, c'est
une catastrophe aujourd'hui, bien
entendu. Vous le savez bien, on en a
déjà parlé l'année dernière, c'est une
catastrophe et je vais pas en reparler
parce que parce que j'ai pas envie de
répéter des trucs. Voilà, si les gens
s'y intéressent, ils vont aller voir
l'ancienne entretien qu'on avait fait
ensemble euh maintenant et puis ils vont
aller voir le film que j'avais fait avec
France 2 et un certain nombre de choses
sur le temps de ser disponible et cetera
et cetera. Je tiens juste à signaler
quand même que le réalisateur de ce film
a été attaqué en justice
euh à un moment donné poursuivi par des
gens du Parti socialiste, ce qui est
quand même assez extraordinaire. Bon,
finalement, je crois qu'ils ont
abandonné les poursuites, mais parce que
enfin voilà.
C'était qui au Parti socialiste ?
Oh, je me souviens plus. C'était je me
souviens plus de leur nom. Enfin bon,
c'est c'est pour vous montrer à quel
niveau de dégradation la classe
politique est tombée, quoi.
Enfin, alors
nous aujourd'hui, nous pensons que bien
entendu, les fonds spéculatifs,
ça c'est une très grande réalité. Bien
entendu, ils sont maintenant dans les
ils sont actionnaires dans pratiquement
toutes les entreprises. Ils arrivent,
ils prennent leur argent et ils s'en
vont et donc c'est catastrophique. Mais
il y a pas que ça. D'abord euh à terme,
ils sont tous perdants aussi hein parce
que même les fonds spéculatifs de toute
façon si il y a une boucle irréversible,
une bifurcation irréversible qui se
produit, bah ils vont l'assumir comme
tout le monde parce que ça personne ne
peut y échapper. Absolument personne. À
partir de là, ce qui est très important,
c'est de diffuser une nouvelle raison de
vivre. Et il faut discuter avec ces
jeunes gens qui font la grève le
vendredi, il faut discuter avec les
gilets jaunes.
Les gilets jaunes, c'est quoi ? Les
gilets jaunes, c'est un mouvement de
gens qui souffrent de tout ça, dont
certains le disent très bien d'ailleurs,
dont certains sont des gens qui le
disent très mal, qui parfois
s'emprennent à des bouqumissaires.
Voilà, il y a des gens d'extrême droite
bien entendu,
d'extrême gauche.
Il y a aussi des gens d'extrême gauche
et il y a des gens qui sont de nulle
part mais qui sont des gilets jaunes
tout simplement. Mais il y a des gens
très bien dans tout ça. Moi je j'ai
écouté justement vous parliez des médias
tout à l'heure, voilà, qui sont plus
grand-chose pour moi. Euh bon, quand ont
eu lieu ces événements qui ont commencé
au mois de novembre, j'ai évidemment
bon je continue à écouter le journal de
France Culture. C'est à peu près tout ce
que j'écoute moi. Mais je parle des
médias audiovisuels.
Je suis évidemment j'ai lu les journaux,
je suis allé sur Mediapart
et qu'est-ce que j'entendais dire ? Bon
ben voilà, ce sont des en gros des gens
qui veulent maintenir l'automobile, qui
veulent pas changer. Bref, c'était
décrit comme des ti parties des anciens
électé de Donald Trump. Ils étaient
décrits comme ça les gilets jaunes
pendant 3 semaines.
Et puis un jour, j'entends
ou je lis dans un journal que qu'est-ce
qu'il demandait au bout de 3 semaines
les gilets jaunes ? Une convention
nationale sur changement climatique.
Alors là, je me dis tiens, faut quand
même que j'aille regarder et comme il
diffuse, ils s'enregistrent, ils se
diffusent. Voilà, je suis allé regarder
leur débat.
Alors, j'en ai vu un qui avait dans le
dos sur son gilet écrit "Nous ne sommes
pas des automobilistes en colère, nous"
enfin bon. Et j'ai écouté ces débats, ce
sont des gens qui réfléchissent, ce sont
des gens très intéressants. Bien sûr, il
y a des gens qui essayent de les
manipuler à l'extrême droite, à
l'extrême gauche ou à l'extrême centre,
mais il y a des gens très très
intéressants là-dedans. Et c'est pour
moi le premier grand mouvement
populaire, très grand mouvement
populaire depuis 1848. En fait, ça
ressemble beaucoup à 1848 d'ailleurs en
France. En France puis dans toute la
dans toute l'Europe. Euh il faut savoir
que les gilets jaunes, il y en a
maintenant aussi dans pas mal d'endroits
au monde. Voilà. Alors, ce que je crois,
c'est que ce sont des gens qui expriment
quelque chose euh qui parfois ils ont du
mal à exprimer mais nous aussi nous
avons du mal à exprimer. Nous qui ne
sommes pas forcément gilets jaunes, nous
avons beaucoup tous beaucoup de mal à
exprimer ce qui se passe parce que c'est
très difficile de penser ce qui se
passe. Pourquoi ? Ça remet en question
toutes les caséres classiques.
Donc bah je vous disais tout à l'heure
en 1962, moi
on m'aurait dit que d'ici à la fin du
21e siècle l'espèce humaine était
menacé. J'aurais jamais cru. J'aurais
dit oui par la bombe atomique mais pas
par son activité. Personne n'aurait
jamais cru comme ça à part quelques-uns.
Il y en avait quelques-uns très rares
dont Martin et deger
qui par ailleurs passé par les nazis.
Bon mais aujourd'hui tout le monde pense
ça à commencer par ceux qui vous disent
"Mais non, il y a pas de réchauffement
climatique." Donald Trump par exemple
qui arrête pas de répéter qu'il n'y a
pas de réchauffement climatique. Ça
Simon Frid analysé ce genre de
comportement. Quand vous trouvez
quelqu'un qui dit toujours en permanence
mais non, je ne veux pas coucher avec ma
mère, ça veut dire qu'il ne pense qu'à
coucher avec sa mère mais qu' en est pas
conscient. C'est-à-dire qu'il le
réprime. C'est ce qu'on appelle de la
censure. Voilà. Mais il l'exprime à
travers un comportement symptomatique.
Voilà. Et quand vous entendez Trump
répéter à tout bout de champ qu'il y a
pas de changement climatique, vous
pouvez être convaincu que c'est un
symptôme du fait que il est très inquiet
du changement climatique. Tout le monde
l' aujourd'hui à commencer par les
Chinois. Je viens de passer euh 5
semaines en Chine et je peux vous dire
que c'est un sujet qui est tout à fait
d'actualité en Chine. Alors euh
aujourd'hui cette question il faut la
prendre à bras le corps. Mais si on veut
la prendre à bras le corps, premièrement
faut de nouveaux concepts. Les concepts
actuellement utilisés pour la
comptabilité, pour l'économie et ça sont
catastrophiques. Ils sont antonymiques
par rapport à la lutte contre
l'anthropocène.
Deuxièmement, il faut adopter des
méthodes nouvelles de travail. Ces
méthodes, c'est celles que nous essayons
de mettre en place en scène Saint-Denis.
Elle elle repose sur ce que nous
appelons la recherche contributive. La
recherche contributive, c'est un concept
que j'avais avancé il y a 4 ou 5 ans
quand j'étais membre du Conseil national
du numérique et ça avait été repris par
le Conseil national du numérique.
Qu'est-ce que c'est la recherche
contributive ? une recherche qui
consiste à dire
il faut impliquer les gens euh à propos
desquels on fait de la recherche. Quand
on fait de la recherche avec des êtres
humains, les êtres humains sont pas des
animaux, ce sont pas des objets, ce sont
des sujets, des sujets qui
réfléchissent. Donc il faut réfléchir
avec eux, faut pas réfléchir sur eux
sans eux. Voilà. Et donc c'est une
méthode qui a été mise en place par
Court Lewin en sociologie américaine il
y a à peu près 70 ans dans les années 40
qui a été reprise ensuite en Norvège,
en Grande-Bretagne et en France surtout
en psychiatrie en France voilà par Félix
Guatari notamment à la la clinique de la
Borde.
Et d'autre part, il faut utiliser
cette méthode de recherche contributive
en utilisant les technologies
contributives qui permettent de
développer ce que
nous appelons donc nous des laboratoires
contributifs. C'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire à pleine commune demain après-midi
par exemple. Non, demain matin, j'ai un
séminaire euh avec ce qu'on appelle la
clinique contributive de Saint-Denis de
enfin, il a plus de la PMI Pier PMI,
c'estàdire centre de protection
maternelle et infantile Pierre Sémar où
nous travaillons depuis maintenant 6
mois sous la direction d'une
pédopsychiatre à son initiative
d'ailleurs avec des péricultrices, des
infirmières, des médecins généralistes,
psychologues, diéticiennes
sur la destruction de l'éducation des
bébés par les smartphones.
et et nous y travaillons comment ? Et
bien, nous faisons des séminaires, ces
gens-là participent, nous travaillons
sur Donald Winicot, Gregory Batson, euh
toutes sortes de références
scientifiques et ces dames qui sont des
dames très occupées, beaucoup je dis ces
dames parce qu'il y a que des femmes
dans cette dans cette PMI. Et bien
depuis quelques temps nous disent "Mais
c'est génial, on nous prend pas pour des
connes. On nous fait des textes
passionnants, ça nous parle, on élève
des bébés, on lit des textes sur des sur
la psychiatrie de l'enfance, de la mère
et cetera et cetera. Elles sont
enchantées et et elles ont repris le
moral parce que je peux vous dire que le
moral, il est très très bas aujourd'hui.
Il est très très bas, y compris parce
qu'on commence à leur dire maintenant
vous allez prendre des tablettes, vous
allez faire des QCM et vous n'alz plus
faire du diagnostic. Vous allez
simplement appliquer tout ça, ça va être
traité automatiquement par les
ordinateurs. Il disent "Mais c'est de la
folie de faire ça, faut pas faire ça."
Mais maintenant, elles sont armé pour
dire pourquoi il faut pas faire ça.
Alors, ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
recherche contributive. Moi, je
travaille avec des chercheurs. Pour le
moment, c'est des post-doctorants.
On a essayé de lancer ça avec des
doctorants, mais ça n'a pas marché parce
que le président de la République,
monsieur Macron, quand il était ministre
de l'économie, avait entendu parler de
ce projet, il nous avait promis qu'il
nous aiderait et cetera, puis
finalement, il nous a jamais aidé. Donc
voilà, on s'est retrouvé le bec dans
l'eau. On a quand même continué à
travailler, à avancer parce que on avait
d'abord engagé des gens sur le terrain,
des habitants, des partenaires
économiques et cetera et cera. Donc on a
décidé de continuer à avancer même sans
l'aide de l'État. On a ni l'aide de
l'État, ni l'aide des collectiv des
collectivités locales et territoriales.
On fait tout nous-même avec l'aide d'un
certain nombre de la fondation de
France, la Casse dépôt et consignation
et des acteurs privés. Et qu'est-ce que
nous essayons de faire ? Nous essayons
de former des laboratoires sur ce
territoire de pleine commune avec des
chercheurs. Donc des chercheurs
professionnels qui sont des gens pour le
moment sont des post-doctorants.
Mais ces postdoctorants, ils travaillent
avec des populations, avec des habitants
et ces habitants eux-mêmes deviennent
des chercheurs. Et on essae demain j'ai
rendez-vous avec Orange d'ailleurs pour
ça pour parler de tout ça. On essaie de
mettre en place des nouveaux types de
plateformes qui sont pas les plateformes
à la façon Amazon ou Facebook mais qui
sont des plateformes contributives avec
une gestion locale de la plateforme
et qui sont des plateformes qui ont pour
but de faciliter la contribution entre
les gens. Pour quoi faire ? Pour d'abord
euh développer des activités de ce type,
je vous parle de la santé, mais on
travaille aussi dans l'alimentation, on
travaille dans le bâtiment, on travaille
dans la mécanique euh et qu'est-ce qu'on
essénie
aussi dans le des bâtiments à énergie
positive. Et qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de
faire ? Bah de créer une nouvelle
économie. C'est une économie qui est
basée sur la lutte contre l'entropie.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire basé sur la
lutte contre l'entropie ? Ben ça veut
dire par exemple ses parents qui ont eu
des expériences malheureuses avec leur
bébés et leurs smartphones. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des bébés
qui prennent pas le sein facilement et
il y a des mamans qui d'un seul coup se
disent tiens si je prends mon smartphone
et que je le montre au bébé, il va il va
se mettre à tété. C'est ce qui se passe.
Alors comme les les mères se passent le
mot, tous les bébés sont exposés au
smartphone à l'âge de quelques jours et
3 ans après, ils sont autistes.
Ça c'est une pathologie qui a été bien
identifiée. C'est la pire celle-là. Mais
il y a pas que ça. Il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de mots malheureusement partout
et pas simplement dans les classes
populaires. Vous pouvez aller dans le
arrondissement, c'est pareil à Noi c'est
pareil. Beaucoup beaucoup de gens sont
détruits par les smartphones mais pas
simplement les smartphones disons par
les écrans au sens large. Ça devient une
pathologie extrêmement grave et c'est de
l'addiction
mais ça produit des ravages véritables
et sur les cerveaux des enfants parce
que parce que un enfant c'est un cerveau
qui se développe et cetera.
Et donc qu'est-ce que nous sommes en
train de faire ? Et bien nous sommes en
train d'essayer de créer une économie
contributive de gens qui sont des
experts de la lutte contre ça. Et ceux
qui sont les meilleurs pour lutter
contre ça, c'est les parents qui ont
vécu ça. Là, on reprend le modèle des
alcooliques anonymes qui a été développé
aux États-Unis. C'est Gregory Bson qui
l'a théorisé, l'anthropologue américain.
Et sur quoi ça repose les alcooliques
anonymes ? sont d'anciens alcooliques
qui soignent des alcooliques et c'est
quatre fois plus efficace que la
psychiatrie que que les que les les la
désintoxication en milieu psychiatrique.
Nous nous pensons que il y a là toute
une activité à développer et cette
activité il faut la financer avec ce
qu'on appelle un revenu contributif.
Voilà le revenu contributif s'inspire du
régime des intermittents du spectacle.
Il donnent de l'argent aux gens pour
qu'ils développent leur savoir et il
conditionne cette allocation de
ressources au fait que ce savoir ces
gens vont le valoriser régulièrement
comme les intermittents doivent avoir de
temps en temps un cacheton pour pouvoir
faire leurs heures comme on dit leurs
507 heures tous les 10 mois. On va pas
reprendre le modèle des intermittents
tel quel. on est en train de discuter
tout ça, le négocier, mais c'est ça
qu'on est en train de de mettre en place
dans toutes sortes de secteurs. Alors
ça, nous pensons que cela permet euh de
créer une nouvelle rationnalité
économique et à un moment donné et bien
de permettre à des gens qui sont des
investisseurs de se remettre à investir
et non pas à spéculer. Parce que le
problème que vous posiez tout à l'heure,
c'est que la finance bancaire est
devenue spéculative et ça ça date de la
fin des années 70. Ça date du moment où
on a cassé toutes les régulations qui
empêchaient par exemple un actionnaire
de rentrer, de sortir comme il voulait
dans une entreprise. Il faut remettre
des règles comme ça. Nous nous pensons
que pour le prouver, il faut
expérimenter. Donc nous sommes en train
d'expérimenter en scène Saint-Denis,
mais nous allons écrire un appel d'offre
et nous demandons à l'ONU de nous
soutenir pour ça. Nous allons avoir
l'ONU avec des acteurs économiques pour
dire mettez de l'argent pour lutter
contre la guerre économique pour pour
mettre en œuvre un traité de paix
économique en permettant à toutes sortes
de pays d'expérimenter des modèles
d'économie contributive de lutte contre
l'entropie. Ça c'est rationnel. Je peux
vous dire que ça intéresse énormément
les acteurs économiques. Ça intéresse
énormément les les militants,
ça intéresse les ingénieurs, ça
intéresse tout le monde. Voilà. Donc il
faut le faire. C'est c'est compliqué
hein. Je suis pas en train de dire que
c'est facile à faire. Euh mais ça c'est
une vraie réponse et aux gilets jaunes
et aux jeunes qui se mobilisent en ce
moment pour leur avenir et qui ont bien
raison de le faire. Donc et par
ailleurs, nous essayons de le faire par
débat contradictoire, c'est-à-dire en
mettant en œuvre les procédures
classiques euh du domaine scientifique,
c'estàd la critique par les pères.
Là là, c'est la version Bernard Stigler,
c'est soft.
On on réfléchit, on développe
localement, on expérimente. Bon, on a 10
ans pour faire ça.
C'est c'est peut-être un peu trop soft.
Il y a pas il y a pas une version un peu
plus euh
coopérative ? On va chercher les mecs
par la peau du et on leur dit maintenant
ça suffit ta spéculation, tu vas faire
une psychothérapie.
Non, ça j'y crois pas du tout. Ça savez,
je vais vous dire une chose,
une façon genre un peu plus maoïste
genou mais ça fait j'ai 67 ans et je
suis rentré dans les mouvements
d'extrême gauche, j'avais même pas 16
ans. Voilà. que ça revienne ça.
Non mais c'est pas que je je crains rien
du tout de
mouement à l'ancienne de l'extrême
gauche.
Non je non je crains je crains pas ça.
Ce que je crois par contre c'est que on
a assez perdu de temps comme ça.
Donc non je crois pas du tout qu'il faut
aller chercher par non ça c'est du
blabla c'est de la posture. Et justement
je pense que il faut passer ce que
j'appelle moi un nouveau compromis
historique. Il y a des acteurs
économiques qui aujourd'hui sont des
capitalistes. Tous les acteurs ou
presque qui n'ont pas qui sont pas passé
par le capitalisme sont effondrés. Il y
a des acteurs qui cherchent à sortir de
ce modèle-el là en passant par le
coopérativisme, l'économie sociale et
solidaire et cetera. Bah regardez ce
qu'ils deviennent. Ils deviennent tous
des entreprises capitalistes. Voilà. Euh
il y a des gens qui développent des
modèles nouveaux auquels je m'intéresse
beaucoup et ça j'y travaille en Sain
Saint-Di. C'est ce qu'on appelle les
communs. Et je le connais par quoi ? par
le software, par le free software parce
que c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert
tous ces sujets. J'ai été moi-même
responsable d'équipe comme ça. Donc je
connais très bien ça. J'y crois
beaucoup. Mais c'est pas du tout euh un
problème dealler prendre les
spéculateurs par du je sais pas quoi.
Non, ça c'est ce qu'on disait au début
du Front populaire et ça a mal fini.
Donc ce que je crois c'est que la vraie
question c'est de se remettre à
réfléchir d'une part et d'autre part à
faire des choses démonstratives et des
choses démonstratives et efficaces.
Voilà, les gens veulent plus du blabla.
Ce qu'ils veulent qu'on fasse des
choses, qu'on démontre des choses. Et
pour ça, il faut proposer des concepts,
des partenaires, des objets, des
terrains et des méthodes. Voilà. Et nous
nous avons tout ça. Alors, je dis pas
qu'on a tout, mais nous avons des
propositions très concrètes à faire.
Après, est-ce que la question se pose de
alors par exemple de mettre un terme à
la spéculation financière ? Oui, bien
entendu.
Prendre l'avion.
Mais prendre l'avion, c'est pas le
problème. C'est pas du tout le problème.
C'est pas comme ça qu'il faut poser les
problèmes. Les problèmes se posent pas
au niveau des comportements individuels.
Se pose se pose au niveau des des
concepts. Par exemple, cette jeune femme
don j'arrive plus à retrouver le nom là,
cette jeune jeune fille de 16 ans, cette
suédoise laquelle on sait
Greta. Voilà. Tunberg. Tunberg.
Bon, elle dit "Je prends pas l'avion".
Elle a refusé de
très bien. Moi, je lui reproche rien du
tout. Mais ça c'est un manque de
réflexion et parfois il faut absolument
prendre l'avion. Voilà, c'est pas la
question et la question c'est pas
supprimer les avions. La question c'est
supprimer le transport des haricots
verts depuis le cagard jusqu'en France
pour faire plaisir au bobo de Paris par
exemple. Ça c'est scandaleux. C'est
scandaleux parce que d'abord les gens
qui cultivent ces haricos verts, ils en
touchent un pour 1000 du prix. Voilà.
Ils ont pas de quoi manger. Ils n'ont
pas de culture vivrière pour eux. Voilà.
Donc le Kenya va très mal et au bord de
la guerre civile. Voilà. Euh ça produit
énormément de CO2 et cetera. C'est ça
qu'il faut c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
travailler et il faut trouver des
modèles économiques où il s'agit pas de
mettre le feu au supermarché hein. Il
s'agit pas de mettre le feu aux avions.
Il s'agit pas de détruire les banques.
On a besoin de banque parce qu'on a
besoin d'investissement. On est dans une
société industrielle, il faut de
l'investissement. On a besoin même de
même de marketing. Moi, je combat le
marketing. Mais mais on a besoin de
marketing. Quand vous créez de
l'innovation, vous avez besoin de
marketer vot. Est-ce que est-ce que le
le marketing de ces 30 dernières années
n'a pas définitivement empoisonné le les
cerveau de consommateurs ?
Mais non, rien n'est définitif. Rien
n'est fin. C'est comme les alcooliques
anonymes. Je vais vous raconter les
alcooliques anonym
finissent très mal hein. Mais
bien entendu, mais rien. Moi je suis un
ancien alcoolique donc je sais de quoi
je parle. Rien n'est définitif. Ça
existe pas définitivement.
Si l'entropie est définitive, oui, mais
du point de vue de la société, bon moi
si vous voulez, j'essaie de j'ai voulu à
un moment donné, j'ai finalement pas
fait écrire un texte qui s'appelait
théorie rationnelle des miracles. Petite
théorie rationnelle des miracles.
Vous savez que la Bible parle de
miracles.
Vous savez aussi qu'elle parle euh de la
poussière.
Enfin plus exactement, c'est la Bible
par parle surtout de la poussière. Quand
je dis la Bible, je parle de la Genèse
en l'occurrence du livre 3 qui dit tout
redev poussière. C'est une formulation
non scientifique de l'entropie.
Et puis vous avez les évangiles
qui parlent de la vie de Jésus-Christ et
qui disent Jésus-Christ peut faire des
miracles. Mais c'est une version
scientifique de la néganthropie.
Néganthropie c'est un miracle.
la néganthropie, les bifurcations
néganthropiques engendrées par des
systèmes ne sont jamais calculables par
le système. Du point de vue de les
probabilités, c'est absolument
improbable. Et ben, ça se produit quand
même. Et bien, du point de vue de
l'intérieur du système, si vous
préférez, c'est improbable. Donc, c'est
miraculeux. Si si ça arrivait, ça serait
un miracle. Bah, ça arrive. Voilà. Donc
ce signe noir,
alors attendez, j'ai pas fini,
excusez-moi. Euh
les alcooliques
anonyme quand il reçoivent un ancien un
alcoolique qui vient les voir en disant
"Je vais me désintoxiquer,
il lui demande "Alors, dis-nous
qu'est-ce que c'était pour toi l'alcool
? Qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça t'a
apporté ?" et cetera. Ah, ça m'a
détruit. C'était ça a été la la la fin
de ma vie. Ça a été, c'est l'horreur,
l'alcool et tout ça.
Et là, il répondent "Bah, tu es pas prêt
pour te désintoxiquer." Parce que si tu
as bu de l'alcool, c'est que ça te
faisait du bien et tu en avais besoin.
Donc quand tu sauras pourquoi c'était
bon pour toi de boire de l'alcool, tu
seras capable de passer autre chose.
Voilà. Si vous voulez, ce que je vais
dire par là, c'est qu'il faut sortir des
idées reçues. Il faut il faut bien voir
que la question fondamentale, c'est la
bifurcation.
Aujourd'hui, la situation est
désespérée. En effet, si vous regardez
là objectivement la situation du monde,
il y a aucune chance que ça on s'en
sorte. Bah, c'est les seules questions
qui méritent qu'on se les pose. Quand il
y a aucune possibilité, c'est là qu'on
se pose de vraies questions. Et bien,
occupons-nous de cette questionlà. Et
cette question là, c'est
oui, il y a des gens qui sont
complètement intoxiqués et cetera par le
marketing. Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous. J'ai écrit une dizaine de
bouquins là-dessus. Donc je suis extrêm
aussi intoxiqué dans les salles de
marché.
Bien entendu. Bien entendu. Et ben il y
en a qui se désintoxiquent.
Il y a de il y a des il y a des gens qui
ont été voilà très très intoxiqués puis
qui sont sont désintoxiqués. Je vais
vous donner deux exemples, trois même.
Dans l'Empire romain, il y a une
pratique qui est apparue qui s'appelait
l'ossium.
C'est une pratique de haute
civilisation, de gens qui d'un seul coup
sont devenus des gens qui voilà
essayaient de vivre bien, de penser, de
vivre sobrement,
d'avoir une belle une vraie belle vie.
Mais une belle vie, ça voulait pas dire
aller se promener avec sa relaxe sur les
Champsélysées comme président Sarkozi.
Non, ça veut dire ça voulait dire vivre
sagement.
Ces gens-là,
Jean-Marie André, un historien, a écrit
un livre sur eux. Il a dit "Voilà
comment sont apparus les gens de l'IUM."
C'était des anciens légionnaires romains
qui avaient massacré des tas de gens.
Ils avaient commis les pires crimes.
C'est eux qui ont construit l'Empire
romain. Donc, ils ont massacré comme des
fous. Et à un moment donné, ils en
pouvaient plus d'être des massacreurs
comme ça.
Moi, j'ai lu ce bouquin euh de
Jean-Marie-André sur l'UM dans la Rome
augustinienne parce qu'un un étudiant en
philosophie de l'université de Lille qui
est devenu depuis quelqu'un qui enseigne
à l'école euh à Valencienne
euh est venu en me disant voilà, j'ai lu
votre bouquin, je parlais de l'osum,
j'ai lu votre bouquin MCR discrédit,
vous parlez de l'osume, je vous offre un
livre voilà qui parle de ça, vous allez
voir. Je lis ce bouquin dans un c'est un
gros livre dans un avion qui m'emmenait
à Tokyo.
Et puis arrivé à Tokyo, je fais des
cours et puis ensuite le professeur
Hidetaka Isida qui m'avait invité me dit
"Est-ce que voudriez pas aller passer 3
jours à Kyoto ? Je vous emmène à Kyoto,
visitez les temples zen de Kyoto. Nous
allons à Kyoto.
Nous nous installons c'était en hiver
dans un temple absolument magnifique
avec son jardin de pierre qui est leur
jardin de pierre le plus connu au monde
qui est un endroit fabuleux. Nous
restons 20 minutes sans parler.
Et le le jardin de pierre fait de
l'effet sur moi parce que les jardins de
pierre ça a un effet un peu hypnotique
et ça ça vous ça vous met dans un état
tout à fait spécial.
Et il détaquida qui savait ça. Au bout
de 20 minutes, il me dit "Bon, est-ce
que vous savez où vous êtes ?" Je dis
"Bah oui, je suis devant un jardin de
pierre." Il me dit "Mais est-ce que vous
savez d'où ça vient ?" Je dis "Non." Ça
a été inventé par les samourailles
qui en fait avaient fait des guerres
terribles, qui avaient massacré des tas
de gens. C'est des guerres civiles au
Moyen-Âge, enfin à la fin du Moyen-Âge
au Japon. Et en fait, il me décrit la
même chose que ce que j'avais lu dans le
bouquin sur les Romains
par Jean-Marie André. C'est comme ça qu'
a été inventé la cérémonité, le jardin
de pierre et le zen japonais.
Maintenant, si vous lisez une nouvelle
que je vous recommande chaudement de
Gustave Lobert
qui s'appelle Saint-Julien
l'hospitalier,
elle raconte comment Julien, donc le
saint est devenu ce saint, un saint.
ordre mandiant, enfin qui est devenu un
un saint comme on les connaît au début
du enfin après l'an 1000 au Moyen-Âge.
Qui c'était celui-là ? Ben c'était un
seigneur qui massacrait, il massacrait
aussi massacrait les animaux lui. Et
puis un jour il a il a il a il a détruit
toute une famille de serre, le mâle, la
femelle et et les fants, les les petits
comme pour rien à l'arbalette. C'est ce
que raconte la légende de Saint-Julien à
l'hospitalier. Et là, il y a le mâle qui
était toujours pas mort est venu vers
lui, s'est dressé comme ça. Il lui a dit
: "Tu tueras ton père et ta mère." Et il
s'est écroulé. C'était donc une parole
comme ça.
Et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Saint-Julien a effectivement tué son
père et sa mère. Je vais pas vous dire
comment. Et après, il est devenu un ça.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que il
y a des bifurcations qui se produisent
dans l'histoire et généralement elles se
produisent après des excès euh qui sont
des excès qui portent les civilisations
à leur propre limite et ça engendre une
nouvelle civilisation.
L'inertie,
l'inertie c'est ce c'est ce quoi ce ce
avec quoi il faut travailler, avec quoi
il faut compter, c'est ce qui par
exemple permet aux machines à vapeur de
fonctionner
et donc il faut savoir s'en servir
intelligemment. Donc il y a de l'inertie
bien entendu. Elle est très souvent un
problème et bien il faut devenir James
Swat et en faire une solution. Donc ce
que je crois c'est que la vraie question
c'est de se dire
les êtres humains puisque là vous me
parlez de l'inertie des êtres humains,
de l'inertie des des administrations, de
l'inertie des des des entrepreneurs, de
l'inertie de tout le monde, de la vôtre,
de la mienne et tout ça. L'inertie c'est
une dimension de l'être humain. Mais il
y a une autre dimension dans l'être
humain. Les êtres humains, ils sont
polarisés. C'est ce que les religions
cherchent à dire d'ailleurs, hein. Le
mot polarisé, il a été produit par
Gilbert Simondon. Qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils sont polarisés ? Ils sont
attirés par une chose et le contraire de
la chose. Ils voudraient être des gens
très bons, très très généreux et tout ça
porté par des idées euh euh fécondes,
originales euh et en même temps, ils
sont ils sont attirés par des pulsions.
Ils sont attirés par tout ce qui
constitue le fond naturel du nivellement
par le bas. C'est ce qu'exploite
aujourd'hui les médias à fond. Voilà,
c'est pour ça que les médias sont
devenus une catastrophe. C'est une
poubelle les médias aujourd'hui. Il y a
pratiquement plus de médias. Il y en a
encore quelques-uns, mais ils sont très
rares qui exploitent pas tout ça. Le
sensationnel, le sexe, le sang et cetera
et cetera, y compris l'incendie de la
Notre Dame parce que cet événement est
évidemment un il m'a fait pleurer cet
événement mais il est exploité d'une
manière indigne, voilà. Et de manière
stupide, quoi qu'il en soit et stupide
que ça
et instrumentalisé surtout. Il est très
instrumentalisé
en tout cas. Bah stupide, pas si stupide
que ça quand on
perme de temps,
pardon
à court terme, c'est pas stupide. Ça
fait du trafic, ça fait de l'audience,
ça fait remonter le prix de l'action.
Ouais, enfin bon,
c'est bien ça, non ?
Ouais,
on voit de plus en plus d'insanité dans
dans les médias quand le prix de
l'action se casse la figure. Non.
Oui. Euh mais je suis pas sûr que enfin
bon, je vais pas parler. Fait qu'est-ce
qu' a fait signer M6 avec Démol ? Je ça
je sais plus. Je m'occup je m'occupe
plus maintenant de ces questionsl. Je
j'ai mis les mains dans les poubelles
pendant longtemps et j'ai décidé de de
ne plus de ne plus me salir les mains.
Donc ça m'intéresse plus du tout. Voilà.
Mais en revanche, ce que je crois c'est
que les êtres humains sont polarisés. En
fait, le problème c'est que les êtres
humains d'une part, ils sont polarisés,
ils sont attirés à la fois par le
meilleur et par le pire, mais
deuxièmement ils sont déégateur. Donc
euh la vraie question fondamentale,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens dénent
qui est terrible. Et quand je leur quand
je dis ça, je leur fais pas du tout le
griff parce que il dénit parce que c'est
pas supportable. Si ce soir à 23h vous
vous dites bah le GC nous dit que d'ici
à 11 ans c'est cuit, vous arriverez pas
à dormir. Alors demain matin vous allez
bosser donc vous avez besoin de dormir.
Donc vous allez essayer de penser à
autre chose et personne n'a le droit de
vous le reprocher. En revanche, le
travail des responsables des chefs
d'état, des responsables d'entreprise et
tout ça, c'est de donner des raisons
d'espérer et pas par la dénégation en
disant "Oui, c'est très mal, il y a la
situation est très grave et il y a des
possibilités et donc on va se donner les
moyens de les trouver et de les
concrétiser." C'est ça la vraie
question. Les gens aujourd'hui font du
déni parce qu'on leur propose rien qui
leur permette d'espérer. Et nous, nous
disons, on peut produire de l'espoir
rationnel. Qu'est-ce que avec un espoir
rationnel ? C'est se donner un objectif
réalisable, même s'il est réalisable à
une chance sur un million. Mais s'il
estable une chance sur un million, il
est possible de le réaliser. Et c'est un
objet de volonté collective.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes le dos au mur.
C'est dans c'est quand on a le dos au
mur que la volonté peut véritablement se
réveiller. Donc il faut réveiller le
monde. C'est à ça que nous essayons de
nous employer. Très concrètement,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que le 2 et le 3 juillet prochain,
nous aurons un séminaire à la maison
Sugère, c'est-à-dire la fondation Maison
des Sciences de l'âme à Paris avec une
trentaine de ces personnes dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure que nous aurons
un colloque au Saint-Pidou, je crois que
c'est le 18 et le 19 décembre prochain
sur ce sujet et que nous nous rendrons
le 10 janvier 2020 à Genève au siège à
l'ancien siège de la société des
nations. pour remettre solennellement
aux Nations- Unies ou à leur
représentant ce texte.
Pardon,
tel une offrande ?
C'est pas simplement une offrande, c'est
une proposition de travailler
sérieusement. Je vais vous dire pourquoi
je dis ça. Il y a beaucoup de
scientifiques dans ce groupe.
Aujourd'hui, on vous empêche de faire de
la science. Les conditions dans
lesquelles on vous fait travailler quand
vous êtes biologiste,
physicien, mathématicien et cetera,
c'est de l'anticcience.
C'est de l'antiscience. Pourquoi je dis
ça ?
On vous dit par exemple qu'aujourd'hui
il faut il faut absolument
renoncer à pouvoir expliquer ce qui se
passe par exemple dans les corrélations
produites par les datas. Mais c'est
absolument scandaleux.
Aristote a expliqué très bien il y a
quand même 2500 ans que ce qui fait que
la science et la science par rapport à
je dirais la pseudoscience des sophistes
de son époque, c'est que le scientifique
doit rendre compte du phénomène de A à
Z.
Et donc on vous apprend que vous allez
maintenant travailler avec des systèmes
de de corrélation he de de probabilité
que ça produit des boîtes noires et vous
pourrez pas expliquer ce qui se passe.
Alors moi je travaille avec des gens, je
vais pas vous dire qui parce que je
voudrais pas leur créer des ennuis mais
euh je travaille avec des gens qui sont
pas du tout d'accord avec ça qui sont
des physiciens, des biologistes et
cetera et qui veulent développer des
instruments scientifiques et on leur dit
"Ah non, maintenant on n plus le droit
de développer vos instruments
scientifiques. Faut aller faut faire des
marchés publics. Il faut acheter des
instruments scientifiques qui sont sur
produits par des industriels du marché
de l'instrument scientifique. Ah oui,
mais il y a des licences chez ces
industriels qui disent le mode de
fonctionnement du système est secret et
vous n'y avez pas accès parce que nous
sommes propriétaires de la licence et ça
c'est antfique. Et mo leur dit
maintenant c'est comme ça qu'il faut
travailler. Ça c'est scandaleux. Et ça
ça produit ce qu'on appelle la post
truth era, c'est-à-dire l'aire de la
postvérité. Les gens ne croient plus à
rien. Les gens, y compris les
scientifiques, ils sont ils sont on les
prive de faire leur travail. Donc il
faut changer tout ça. Quand je dis ça,
je suis pas contre les big data, hein.
Moi-même, je je développe des
technologies de ce genre dans mon
institut et je travaille avec énormément
de gens dans l'intelligence
artificielle,
dans les mathématiques appliquées et
cetera et cetera. Ce que je dis, c'est
qu'il faut s'en servir intelligemment.
Pour le moment, on s'en sert d'une
manière absolument ridicule et stupide.
tirer le le le politique dans la boucle.
Est-ce que les big data sont trop
instrumentalisés par nos politiques pour
leur faire dire à peu près ce que ce
qu'on voulait ?
Les politiques, que je commence à ne
penser qu'il y en a plus des politiques.
Macron.
Macron c'est un politique. C'est quoi ?
C'est un premier de la classe c'est un
quoi ? Allez il est gentil Macron. Non.
Allez je me fais la VO. Un un politique
c'est pas c'est pas quelqu'un qui gère
donc c'est quelqu'un qui pense voilà
qui cope.
Non non non ça c'est pas un politique.
Les politiques sont des gens qui
pensent. Et penser ça veut dire mettre
c'est pas c'est pas se caler sur le
dernier édito je sais pas quoi. Zcho ou
ou ou du monde ou de libération. C'est
c'est pas ça à penser. Euh donc ça pense
plus tout ça. Donc euh non, ce que je
crois c'est que il faut se remettre à
penser. Je connais plein de gens qui ont
envie de penser, y compris dans la
fonction publique, la très haute
fonction publique. Je peux pas vous dire
qui non plus parce que là aussi j'ai pas
envie de faire des problèmes. Mais il y
a des gens de la très haute fonction
publique qui s'intéressent beaucoup à ce
que nous faisons et qui aimeraient bien
y participer. On va
on va passer deux trois questions
internet qui sont arrivées.
D'accord. La première, vous n'êtes pas
pour la décroissance mais vous parlez du
rapport midose. N'y a-t-il pas une
contradiction ?
Mais je parle du
rapport Midose.
Ouais. Mose. Mose. Ouais.
Mose. Excusez-moi.
Non non, excusez, c'est moi qui m'excuse
mais euh vous ne pensiez vous ne pensez
pas qu'il faut une décroissance de la
consommation énergétique ?
Alors
bien sûr que oui qu'il faut mais c'est
pas une décroissance. Faut limiter la
consommation énergétique. C'est pas du
tout une décroissance. Regardez en Chine
par exemple, il y a plus de de
pratiquement plus de moteur thermique
sauf dans les villes de nouveau riches
comme Hango, où il y a des quelques
Ferrari, Lamborghini et autres trucs
comme ça qui font beaucoup de bruit qui
font et ils sont contents avec ça. Bon
mais sinon les voitures sont
électriques, les vélos sont électriques,
les motos sont électriques, il y a pas
de bruit.
Il y a pas de bruit mais ça consomme
tout autant d'énergie.
Ça consomme ça produit beaucoup moins de
CO2 en tout cas. Donc donc c'est une
énergie beaucoup plus enfin c'est c'est
beaucoup plus satisfaisant.
l'électrification. Je vous signale que
aujourd'hui, vous le savez, madame
Hidalgo ne laissera plus rentrer les
voitures thermiques à diesel en 2023 à
Paris et en 2030, aucune voiture
thermique. Donc, il faudra tout
électrifier.
2023, ce sera la première catégorie de
diesel, puis ensuite la deuxième
catégorie de diesel
et ensuite en 2030, c'est les voitures
essences. Voilà. Euh non, mais c'est un
sujet et c'est pas c'est pas nouveau.
C'est tout garde qui a démarré ça tout
et et ça et c'est dans le monde entier.
Et c'est dans le monde entier. Et donc
euh ce sont des il faut il faut parler
très précisément. Maintenant, limiter la
consommation énergétique, c'est pas du
tout de la décroissance, c'est de la
croissance. J'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle pour en finir avec la
mécroissance. Ce qu'on appelle la
croissance, growth en anglais, c'est une
mécroissance. C'est pas du tout une
croissance. La croissance, c'est ce qui
permet le développement de l'avenir. Ce
dont quoi on est, c'est pas du tout de
la croissance. C'est de la c'est ce qui
empêche le développement de l'avenir.
C'est ce que nous dit le GC. Donc ce
qu'il faut c'est réinventer la
croissance. Faut pas inventer la
décroissance. Il faut s'occuper des
350000 bébés qui naissent tous les
jours. Après, est-ce qu'il faut vivre en
consommant 600 L de flotte par jour, en
consommant je sais pas combien de
d'essence et cetera et cetera ?
Certainement pas. Et c'est tout à fait
possible de vivre autrement. ces
légionnaires romains dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure, ce sont des gens
qui avaient été annoblis par le par
l'empereur par l'empereur de Rome,
voilà, de et qui donc était dans
l'opulence totale. Ils avaient des
villas comme on appelle ça, des
assiendas avec des esclaves et cetera et
ce et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont décidé de
faire ? De vivre raisonnablement. dire
de c'était pas de diminuer leur train de
vie, leur problème, c'était de vivre
intelligemment et de vivre bien. Donc le
problème c'est de vivre bien. Et vivre
bien, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Et
bien ça veut dire réapprendre à manger
ensemble par exemple. Ça veut dire
réapprendre à faire la cuisine. Ça veut
dire toutes sortes de choses comme ça.
Moi, je travaille avec Danon sur ces
questions. Je travaille avec des
entreprises qui qui parce que ce sont
des gens qui savent très bien que ces
transformations là, elles sont très
profondes et que si ils ne les
anticipent pas, ils disparaîtront. Donc
après, comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure, ce sont des compromis à
trouver. Tout est à faire de compromis
puisque nous sommes nous sommes dans un
monde fini. Et donc euh bien sûr qu'il
faut il faut diminuer la consommation
énergétique d'hydrocarbure,
d'électricité et cetera et cetera. Euh
mais pourquoi est-ce que les gens
consomment tant ? C'est parce qu'ils
sont pas bien. C'est une c'est une
logique addictive. C'est
le marketing.
C'est c'est le marketing mais qui
exploite la frustration. C'est bon, un
jour, vous savez, j'ai déjeuné moi, une
fois de je me suis retrouvé dans un
dîner à côté de la dame qui chez Dior a
créé la la la le le parfum addicte.
Voilà.
et on a discuté sur ce tru-là. Elle m'a
dit "Bah oui, l'addiction, bon, j'allais
je venais de publier un bouquin sur
l'addiction. Euh le capitalisme
aujourd'alisme purement addictif.
Demain, d'ailleurs dans cette clinique
contributive dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure, j'accueille un chercheur
anglais qui s'appelle Gérald Moo qui a
fait un énorme travail sur ce que c'est
que l'addiction et le système
d'opinergique et les conditions dans
lesquelles fonctionne l'addiction.
Aujourd'hui, on est dans un un système
qui qui font qui est basé sur la ruine
des gens, de l'environnement des gens et
au bout du compte de la biosphère au
sens de Vladimir Wernatski. Donc, il
faut développer une vraie croissance.
Alors, j'ouvre une parenthèse.
Le sevrage le sevrage du toxicoman à
l'héroïne, ça se passe pas très bien en
général. C'est c'est une période
douloureuse. C'est la période qui
demande une conduite introspective
forte.
des épaules, une volonté, un cap,
même une famille autour, une société
autour pour pour sortir les gens de de
cette addiction. Est-ce que je peux me
faire un parallèle douux avec le
capitalisme ? Est-ce que le sevrage du
capitalisme,
prédateur, sans limite, sans foil lois,
mégalomane ne va pas entraîner des
convulsions délétaires et irréversibles
pour notre société. la stabilité de
notre société.
Bah alors d'abord ces questions là, moi
j'y ai travaillé pendant plusieurs
années avec l'hôpital Marmotan qui est
spécialisé dans lavage des traders à la
cocaïne,
désintoxication de l'héroïne puisque
c'est Claude Alenstein qui a créé cet
hôpital il y a déjà pas mal d'années et
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec son
successeur qui s'appelait Marc Valleur.
Maintenant il a pris sa retraite.
Et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est que
cet hôpital ? Ça c'est un hôpital où on
soigne des on soigne des toxicomanes à
l'héroïne. Plus seulement. Maintenant,
on travaille aussi sur le jeu,
l'addiction au jeux vidéo, le shopping
compulsif, enfin tous ces trucs là. On a
dictologie, pas simplement à Marmon.
C'est des sujets sur lesquels je
travaille beaucoup. On peut très bien
désintoxiquer les gens. Effectivement,
c'est douloureux. Et je voulais
pas faut pas du tout les enfermer. Non,
non, non. Surtout pas, justement pas.
Euh il faut partir de gens qui se sont
désintoxiqués pour les intoxiquer. Je
vous l'ai dit, moi-même, j'ai fait des
cures désintoxication et ce que je crois
c'est que la question fondamentale c'est
d'une part de croire au dans les gens.
Deuxièmement de étudier un petit peu les
sujets dont on parle. C'est-à-dire c'est
il y a des gens qui travaillent sur ces
questions depuis des décennies
maintenant avec des résultats très
positifs. Donc il faut les regarder. Moi
la première fois que j'ai posé ces
question Marc Valor, je l'ai rencontré
parce que je travaillais sur les
téléspectateurs en 2004. Téléama
documentaires.
Pardon ? Il a fait des très bons
Oui, mais Telérama avait avait publié
une enquête en 2004 disant 56 % des
Français n'aiment pas la télévision
qu'il regarde, celle qu'il regarde.
Et donc j'avais en passant par un ami
psychanalyste,
j'arrive plus à retrouver son nom, j'ai
Clint,
j'avais contacté Marc Valur qui était
donc le celui qui avait succédé à Claude
Olivenstein à Marmoton et je lui avais
demandé "Est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
ça ressemble à un
discours de toxicoman, c'est-à-dire qui
est arrivé au stade où le toxicoman dit
"Je voudrais décrocher mais je peux
plus, c'est trop tard." Voilà, il m'a
dit "Oui, c'est typique." Pourquoi ?
Parce que qu'est-ce qu'il disait à ces
téléspectateurs ? "Je déteste la
télévision que je regarde mais j'ai
besoin de la regarder." Après, moi j'ai
fait beaucoup d'études sur le j'ai lu
beaucoup d'enquêtes qui ont été faites
sur ce problème et j'ai trouvé une
enquête dans le Maryland qui a été faite
pendant 30 ans sur 40000 familles
américaines.
Et qu'est-ce qu'elle dit ces familles
américaines ? au bout de 30 ans de
télévision de consommation à haute dose,
elles sont déprimées et cetera, mais
elles disent "Mais surtout ne coupez pas
la télé parce que sinon on se tape tous
dessus." Si vous si vous arrêtez la
télé, on sait plus parler, on sait plus
voilà, ça c'est l'intoxication. Après,
il y a des procédures de
désintoxication. Il faut faire que la
désintoxication devienne une activité
économique et que cette activité
économique, elle soit rentable. Mais
rentable dans la durée, pas prédatrice,
rentable.
Euh c'est pour ça que pour moi le
problème c'est pas de se désintoxiquer
du capitalisme, c'est de se
désintoxiquer d'un mode de
fonctionnement actuel du capitalisme qui
est le modèle spéculatif. Quand je vous
dis ça, moi j'ai combattu le le
capitalisme toute ma vie. Donc je me
suis engagé très tôt dans contre le
capitalisme. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est pas
le problème de lutter contre le
capitalisme. Le problème c'est de lutter
contre l'autodestruction du capitalisme.
Et après, je crois pas que le
capitalisme durera toute la vie. Je
pense qu'il y aura d'autres choses qui
s'engendreront. On verra bien quoi. Mais
par contre ce que je sais c'est que tous
les modèles qui avaient été proposés
comme alternative au capitalisme se sont
écroulés tous. Et comme il nous reste
très peu de temps et bien arrêtons de
prendre des postures et essayons de de
travailler vraiment sur des sujets en
produisant des résultats et ça c'est
tout à fait possible.
Alors autre question d'internet. Vous
citez Danon et d'Assu dans vos
partenaires qui sont parmi les plus
grands producteurs d'entreprise
d'enthropie au monde. Est-ce que vous
pensez qu'ils sont sincères ? Est-ce que
leur sincérité est avérée ou est-ce que
vous avez pas peur de vous faire traiter
de naïf ?
Bah non, moi je fais alors c'est Danon
c'est c'est avec Emmanuel Faber qui en
est le patron que que je travaille. Je
pense qu'elle est tout à fait convaincu
par ce que nous racontons et qu'il est
convaincu que les modèles classiques
disons de l'industrie agroélimentaire
on sont derrière nous maintenant et
qu'il faut produire autre chose. Voilà,
je suis convaincu qu'il qu'il y
travaille sérieusement. Pourquoi ? Parce
que par exemple, il a développé au
Sénégal des relations avec l'agriculture
locale pour essayer d'inventer des
productions locales et non pas d'arroser
le monde entier avec ses yaourts et
cetera. et cetera et j'ai rencontré
plusieurs personnes de cette entreprise
et tous ces gens-là se posent beaucoup
de questions et de bonnes questions.
C'est c'est le boycotte qui les a secoué
?
Non, je crois pas. Je pense ce sont des
gens intelligents et rationnels tout
simplement et qui tiennent à exister
encore dans 20 ou 30 ans. Ils ont des
enfants, ils ont des petits enfants, euh
ils ont puis ce sont des gens, ce sont
des gens des gens bien. Donc voilà, ils
sont alors des gens bien, on peut leur
reprocher des capitalistes et gagner
beaucoup d'argent bien entendu, mais il
y a des gens bien qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent et il y a des des gens très
pauvres qui sont pas du tout des gens
bien. Donc le problème n'est pas de
savoir s'ils sont riches ou pas riches.
Je pense qu'il y a des gens rationnels,
d'autres qui ne le sont pas. C'est tout
à fait autre chose.
Et ceux qui sont ceux qui sont
irrationnels et qui ont un
haut degré de pouvoir, une position qui
il y en a plein.
Bah bien entendu.
Et on fait comment pour les neutraliser
ou ?
Bah on verra bien. Faut être plus fort
queeux. Mais ça c'est tout à fait
possible d'être plus fort que vous savez
moi je crois beaucoup à David et
Goliath. Voilà. Donc j'ai jamais cru que
les puissants étaient plus forts que
moi. Moi jamais j'ai cru ça. J'ai jamais
cru que j'étais plus fort que non plus.
Ce que je pense, c'est qu'il faut jamais
intérioriser ce genre de truclà. Voilà.
Et qu'il faut jamais renoncer, faut être
courageux tout simplement. Après,
d'assaut, c'est d'assau système avec qui
je travaille. C'est pas d'assaut
armement hein. Et d'assau système,
qu'est-ce que c'est ? une entreprise,
c'est une des meilleures entreprises
françaises et européennes. C'est une
entreprise qui a développé des
technologies de conception assisté par
ordinateur à travers un logiciel très
connu qui s'appelle Katia qui est
utilisé dans le monde entier par
l'aéronautique, par la métallurgie, par
et c'est ce qui ce sont des logiciels
qui permettent à des ingénieurs de
produire mieux et plus vite dans des
conditions disons de d'intelligence
développer des systèmes d'intelligence
collective entre ingénieurs. Nous nous
avons ils
ont fait un très bon réacteur. Ils ont
fait un très bon réacteur avec Katia.
Non. Bon
bon, ils ont fait plein de choses. Mati
c'est utilisé par tous les industriel
aujourd'hui quasiment hein. Il y a il y
a quasiment pas de concurrent Katia
aujourd'hui sauf dans le bâtiment mais
ça je vais pas en parler même si je m'y
intéresse beaucoup. J'en discute
beaucoup avec d'assau système mais si je
vous dis ça c'est parce que la
discussion que j'ai engagé avec d'assau
système c'était il y a 3 ou 4 ans. C'est
quand j'étais membre du conseil national
de numérique. J'ai fait la connaissance
du directeur général adjoint de
l'assoystème qui s'appelle Pascal
d'allose qui était aussi directeur de la
recherche de système. C'est quelqu'un de
très très bien. Il est aussi maintenant
directeur financier de système. Et
voilà, je lui ai parlé de mes idées sur
l'entropieopie. C'est un homme très
intelligent, c'est un ingénieur au
départ
et et je lui ai parlé des conditions
dans lesquelles on pouvait implanter sur
des plateformes ce genre de de modèle
néganthrropique. Et ça l'intéresse
beaucoup parce que lui, qu'est-ce qu'il
a besoin de produire avec des groupes
d'ingénieurs ? De l'intelligence, donc
éviter la prolarisation des ingénieurs.
Voilà. Moi, c'est ça le genre de
relation que j'ai avec les industriels,
c'est pas des postures. Et
vous avez des contacts avec la famille
d'assaut ?
Ah non, pas du tout. Non.
Alors, autre question d'internet. Est-ce
que vous connaissez la série Black
Mirror ?
J'en ai entend souvent parler par mes
étudiants, mais je l'ai jamais vu.
Vous avez pas d'épisode préférés donc.
OK. Bah,
je me dis qu'il faudrait que je le
regarde, tout le monde m'en parle. Donc
voilà.
Oh, ça se peutêtre je vais peut-être le
regarder un jour. Ouais,
c'est pas mal. On arrive à la fin de
notre interview pratiquement.
Euh, un mot sur le Brexit.
Bah le Brexit c'est une catastrophe pour
moi. C'est une catastrophe d'abord pour
l'Angleterre et pour l'Irlande. Je pense
surtout à l'Irlande parce que c'est un
particulièrement juste pour elle
puisqu'elle a voté contre le Brexit et
finalement elle va en subir les effets
peut-être plus que tout le monde. C'est
une catastrophe. Je travaille beaucoup
avec l'Angleterre donc j'ai beaucoup
d'amis anglais et et donc je vois bien
quel effet ça a sur eux. Je pense une
catastrophe pour l'économie anglaise.
Après la grande la grande question c'est
pourquoi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
représente le Brexit ? La le Brexit est
peut-être un précurseur des élections du
26 mai prochain. Non pas que les gens
vont sortir que les Belges ou les
Allemands ou les Espagnols vont sortir
de l'Union européenne, mais c'est quand
même le le
symptôme d'un échec catastrophique de
l'Europe. Voilà. Et donc moi je suis un
proe européen mais je suis j'ai voté non
au traité constitutionnel de 2005. C'est
pour ça que nous avons créé ars
industrialiste. C'était pour essayer de
penser un avenir de l'Europe au-delà de
ce traité constitutionnel. Euh, j'ai été
scandalisé par les élections européennes
de 2004 où la où le Parlement européen
avait fait afficher dans les métros à
Paris euh vous êtes européen, vous êtes
consommateur, nous sommes là pour
défendre vos intérêts de consommateur.
Et donc pour moi, c'était honteux de
dire ça parce que c'était complètement
nié la citoyenneté européenne et la
citoyenneté tout court. Donc, je suis je
suis un européophile mais aujourd'hui
l'Europe n'existe pas. Aujourd'hui,
l'Europe c'est un espace d'extension des
modèles ultralibéraux. euh à toute
l'activité et je pense c'est une
catastrophe. Et donc le Brexit est une
conséquence de cette absence de
politique que je connais bien parce que
j'ai été directeur de l'INA quelques
temps. J'allais souvent à Bruxelles et
je discutais beaucoup avec des
commissaires européens ou des
fonctionnaires de de l'Europe. Je
connais je connais assez bien la
politique industrielle européenne. Enfin
en gros, pour vous dire ce que j'en
pense, c'est qu'il y en a pas de
politique industrielle en Europe et que
ça c'est le problème. Si vous allez en
Chine, il a une politique industrielle.
Au Japon, il y a une politique
industrielle. Aux États-Unis, il y a une
politique industrielle. Mais en Europe,
il n'y en a pas. Ce qui est très
paradoxal puisque une grande partie des
meilleurs scientifiques qui travaillent
aux États-Unis viennent de France,
d'Allemagne, de Belgique et cetera. Donc
c'est là qu'on forme les souvent les
meilleurs scientifiques, les meilleurs
ingénieurs mais ils restent pas en
Europe parce que on leur propose rien.
Donc l'Europe c'est un échec
catastrophique. Je pense qu'on va le
payer très très cher dans un mois.
J'en suis absolument désolé. Et nous
nous essayons aussi dans ce groupe de
travailler à un au-delà de
l'effondrement européen pour aussi
reconstruire l'Europe parce que je pense
que l'Europe a une responsabilité
face à l'anthropocène historique. C'est
elle aussi qui a déclenché tout ça quand
même et que elle a aussi des ressources
exceptionnelles. Ça reste le continent
le plus riche du monde même si ça a
beaucoup baissé la richesse de l'Europe
mais ça reste le continent le mieux
éduqué du monde, le mieux protégé sur le
plan médical et cetera. Et et donc il y
a il y a une très très grande
euh culture en Europe et à partir de là,
je pense qu'il y a de quoi relancer un
projet européen, mais certainement pas
avec les dogmes de la Commission
européenne et des soi-disants
représentants
des nations actuelles au Parlement
européen parce que là, je pense c'est
catastrophique.
À la Commission européenne, il y a un
alcoolique ou pas ? plusurs.
Euh si je vous dis la chrétinisation de
l'Europe par le lobby américain, ça vous
fait penser à quoi ?
Ah bah ça me parle énormément bien
entendu. Je pense que c'est tout le
problème.
Vous savez, j'ai écrit euh
quand j'étais directeur général adjoint
de Lina, c'était ça ma position,
je j'avais dans mes attributions le
conseil au gouvernement. Voilà, sur la
politique industrielle de l'audiovisuel.
Donc, je faisais des notes au
gouvernement et donc euh quand le 3
avril 1997 la FCC, la Commission
fédérale des communications américaines
a annoncé qu'en 2003, elle demandait à
toutes les stations de radio et de
télévision de passer au tout numérique
et qu'en 2006, elle fermait toutes les
fréquences analogiques.
J'ai écrit au premier ministre qui était
Lionel Jospin qu'en plus je connaissais
personnellement en disant voilà il faut
une politique tout à fait nouvelle
européenne et je me suis fait jeter
je me suis fait jeter par David Kessler
que je connais très d'ailleurs
personnellement très bien aussi qui m'a
dit mais tout ça c'est des bêtises.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il m'a dit ça ? C'est
parce que je lui disais mais la
télévision ça passera sur internet à
partir de 2000.
Et donc il m'a rayonné en me disant mais
il faut développer la télévision
numérique terrestre. Je dis ma
télévision numérique terrestre ça va
coûter extrêmement cher et c'est une
technologie déjà obsolète. Voilà. Donc
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on m'a
répondu ? LINA doit doit être privatisé.
Il faut aller sur le marché. C'est le
marché qui a une intelligence
stratégique, c'est pas les gens comme
toi. Et c'est une catastrophe parce que
la TNT a été développée. C'est un
gaspillage honteux. Voilà. Pendant ce
temps-là, on a laissé se développer bah
tout ce qui a conduit à YouTube et
cetera. Euh non, c'est une voilà et ça
c'est l'effet de d'un d'un lobbying
idéologique en fait de la révolution
conservatrice au niveau européen sur
Jospin comme sur tous les chefs d'état
de de cette époque. Voilà et c'est ce
qu'il faut dépasser.
Si je vous dis le boumissariat,
bah c'est ça a de l'avenir.
A de l'avenir.
Pourquoi ? qu'un bou émissaire en grec,
ça se dit un pharmacos.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que le pharmacos ?
J'ai écrit un livre là-dessus. Ça
s'appelle le livre s'appelle
pharmacologie du Front National. Quand
vous souffrez d'un pharmacone, je vous
disais tout à l'heure, tous les
artifices sont des pharmacas. Par
exemple, si vous prenez de l'aspirine,
ça vous peut vous donner mal à
l'estomac. Donc ça vous soulage la tête
mais ça vous fait un trou dans
l'estomac. Si vous ne savez pas vous
servir de votre smartphone, il va vous
intoxiquer, il va vous ruiner, il va
vous détruire votre bébé et cetera et
cetera. Qu'est-ce que vous êtes plus
précieux dans la vie, encore plus que la
prunelle de vos yeux et cetera ? Ce sont
des éléments dangereux.
Il se trouve que quand c'est pas bien
euh prescrit ces éléments dangereux
comme on doit prescrire les
antibiotiques et cetera et cetera d'une
manière savante, voilà, et bien ça fait
ça fait que les gens subissent les
conséquences.
Aujourd'hui, une grande partie des
classes populaires dans le monde entier,
pas simplement en France, subissent les
conséquences néfastes de la technologie,
du pharmacon industriel. Qu'est-ce
qu'elles font dans ce cas-là ces gens-là
? C'est c'est qu'est-ce que nous faisons
? Parce que nous sommes tous là. Nous
nous en prenons à quelqu'un d'autre en
général. Alors ça peut être le voisin,
ça peut être ses propres enfants, ça
peut être sa femme. C'est assez souvent
le cas. Si vous avez remarqué ça, Alain
Renel a très bien montré dans un de ces
films, vous vous faites maltraiter par
votre chef de service.
Vous dites rien parce que vous dites "Si
je dis quelque chose, je me fais virer."
Donc donc vous vous taisez mais quand
vous rentrez chez vous, vous mettez une
baffe à votre gosse ou ou à votre femme.
Ça arrive encore ce genre de chose.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous avez besoin
d'expulser
la violence que vous avez subi, la faire
subir à quelqu'un d'autre. Ça c'est la
bêtise. Il y a un type s'appelait
Jésus-Christ qui disait "Mais faut pas
faire ça, faut tendre l'autre jour. Je
suis pas chrétien du tout, je suis pas
religieux du tout." Ce que je veux dire
par contre, c'est que toute la
civilisation, qu'elle soit chrétienne ou
pas chrétienne, elle consiste à
interrompre ces ces circuits de la
vengeance, voilà, ou de ou de ou de la
victimisation des des gens qui qui n'y
sont pour rien. Voilà. Euh donc le bouqu
émissaire c'est ça, un bou émissaire,
c'est celui qui est victime de quelque
chose dans quoi il n'a rien à voir, mais
il subit à la place de quelqu'un d'autre
ou de quelque chose d'autre. Voilà,
aujourd'hui, malheureusement, c'est ce
qui nous menace et dans un contexte
extrêmement tendu sur le planétaire et
dans le monde entier, c'est très très
dangereux et ça peut conduire à ce que
j'appelle la guerre civile mondiale.
Mais ça, il faut l'éviter à tout prix et
c'est possible. Oui, si si je vous dis
Julien Assange,
bah Julian Assange,
c'est quelqu'un, je suis très malheureux
de savoir ce qui lui arrive, vraiment
très malheureux.
Un jour, quelqu'un est venu me voir en
me disant "Assan, j'aimerais bien te
rencontrer."
Alors, parce qu'il a du il avait du
temps à l'ambassade de l'Équateur à
Londres. Il lisait beaucoup. il avait lu
un de mes bouquins donc il voulait me
rondre prê mais j'ai dit très bien je
vais aller le voir. Je suis allé voir à
Sing
une demi-journée avec lui à Londres
on a même eu le projet d'écrire un livre
ensemble
parce que c'est un type très savant. Il
a fait des études de physique.
Euh il réfléchit beaucoup. Il a aussi
une pratique extraordinaire
et courageux.
et j'avais ce
projet de d'écrire ce livre avec lui.
J'ai aussi fait une journée au centre
Pompidou pour lui. Voilà, c'était 5 ans
d'incarcération de J. Il y a plein de
gens qui sont venus, des gens très
connus. Voilà, on a fait une espèce de
je peux dire une manifestation pour la
libération de Singe. Et puis il a il a
fait une énorme bêtise.
Il a contribué à l'élection de Donald
Trump. Ça c'est une réalité.
C'est une réalité. Il a effectivement,
je crois pas mal
coopéré avec la Russie. Voilà. Et
vous avez des preuves ?
Bah, j'en ai des preuves matérielles.
Non, mais tout le monde le sait, tout le
monde le dit et ne l'a jamais contesté.
En plus, il avait un compte à régler
avec madame Clinton. Ce que je comprends
hein, parce que Hillary Clinton s'est
comporté, enfin avec lui, elle a dit des
choses abominables et puis par ailleurs,
c'est une bonne femme que je n'aime pas
du tout. à peine plus que Donald Trump.
Sauf que Donald Trump, il met en danger
la planète entière.
Euh Clinton n'aurait jamais fait ça. Non
non non non.
Bien sûr que non. Bien sûr que non. Elle
est pas elle est pas dingue comme lui.
Donc non, il faut pas
plus mégalo. Non.
Ah non, mais ça c'est autre chose.
Non non, Trump c'est un homme
extrêmement dangereux. Donc voilà, j'ai
pu communiquer avec Jilan S depuis cette
cette affaire là. Je lui en veux comme
la très grande majorité des Américains
parce que c'est aussi à cause de ça que
je peux plus aller aux États-Unis. Mais
mais après je évidemment je suis très
triste de voir ce qui lui arrive
euh et j'espère que ça va s'arranger.
Mais je suis plutôt très pessimiste à
cet égard. Autre autre question. Quand
la cupidité et le narcissisme deviennent
les valeurs dominantes,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ce sont pas des
valeurs,
c'est des dévalorisations dominantes. Et
bien euh il faut, je vais devoir
m'arrêter bientôt, il faut précisément
lire Nietzsche et il faut lire mon
dernier livre sur Nietzsche
est-ce que vous avez un
niilisme, ça s'appelle
dernière question.
Donc il y a plus de valeur dans le
niilisme. On est en train de vivre
l'accomplissement du niilisme par quoi ?
Par le calcul. Et c'est ce que c'est ce
que le Nietzsche décrivait comme le
règne des moyennes. Voilà, tout est
transformé en moyenne. Euh et du coup,
il y a plus de valeur. Justement, quand
je dis il y a plus de valeur, c'est pas
au sens réactionnaire, il faut défendre
nos valeurs et cetera. Non, ce que je
veux dire, c'est qu'il y a plus de il y
a le goût de la vie même est en train de
s'effondrer. Ça c'est ce que Nietzsche
appelait le nilisme. Après, il faut lire
Nietzsche et il faut lire mon dernier
livre. Qu'appelle-t-on pensé avec un A ?
La dernière question, c'est pas une
question, c'est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, une bouteille à
la mer.
Bah, il faut suivre la consigne arrêter
d'aller au lycée le vendredi et puis il
faut suivre ce qu'on va faire au champ
de Pidou au mois de décembre prochain.
Bernard Stigler, merci,
à bientôt. À bientôt.
[Musique]